so people at the end of their life they
all pretty much say the same things i
wish i'd worked less i'd wish i spent
more time with my friends and family i
wish i'd allowed myself to be happy i
wish i'd lived my life and not the life
that other people expected off me
wrong chatterjee welcome in the show
chris delighted to be back on welcome
how is it in the uk what's happening
it's hot at the moment it's sunny i'm
very warm in my studio at the moment so
that that's a good thing you're
definitely missing some british sun at
the moment
but um your life's pretty good mate if
i'm honest life
life feels good a lot of the time these
days and um
yeah i gotta say i feel this kind of
level of
calmness and contentment
that i don't think i've really had
before so yeah yeah i'm feeling in a
pretty good place if i'm honest you say
in your new book that you think
happiness is a skill and it seems like
that's been something that you've worked
at here as well right that calmness is
something that you've had to cultivate
it's not something that you've randomly
stumbled upon
i've not felt this way for most of my
life absolutely
um
i think i've really thought about
happiness
in the early part of my life i i think
like many people i thought happiness was
this kind of
vague concept that i knew i wanted but
like i didn't know how to get it i kind
of thought you know at some point in
life when
everything goes my way and i've got a
smile on my face the whole time you know
i'll probably be happy
but you know as you've you know from
reading the new book it's
it's not that at all i think we get
happiness wrong i think society gets
happiness wrong certainly a lot of
society i think society confuses
happiness with success
or we often think that happiness is
it's that billboard image where we see
you know the smiling couple uh on a
beach uh with their kids and the ocean
behind them and we think that's
happiness and that's our aspirational
idea of where i want to get to one day
and
i am convinced more and more
that happiness is a skill it's a skill
that we can develop it's a skill that we
can get better at
we can practice it every day
and the more we practice it
the happier we feel and i think
fundamentally
especially when we be very clear what we
mean by happiness i think fundamentally
that's what every human really wants
what do you mean by happiness
for me happiness has
three core components
alignment contentment and control
and this is the model of core happiness
that i've really been working on over
the past couple of years
and that i've been writing about
because
a lot of people say things like you know
it's not about happiness about meaning
and purpose you know it's not happiness
it's joy it's not happiness it's this
and and i thought well okay
you can say the word happiness to 10
different people i think they will have
10 different interpretations of what
that word means to them so i thought
it's really important at the start of a
conversation or a book that you define
what you mean so
for me i have this concept called core
happiness
as opposed to something that i call junk
happiness so
junk happiness
i think is what we often mistake for
real deep meaningful happiness and
that's you know stuff that we might you
know have a few beers with our friends
or
um spend a few hours scrolling instagram
or going to the casino and gambling and
again to be really clear
context is everything because i'm not
saying that those things are necessarily
good or bad
the problem with those things i think is
if we do them too often
so too frequently
and if we confuse them and think that
that's what's giving us that deep level
of happiness i think that's where we run
into problems
so core happiness
has these three components right
alignment contentment and control so
what do i mean by that
alignment
this is when your inner values and your
external actions
match up
it's when the person who you really want
to be the person who you actually really
are inside and the person who you
actually show up as in the world are one
and the same that's alignment right so
the more we can become aligned in our
life
i'm saying that we're going to
strengthen that alignment leg of this
core happiness stool
the second leg is contentment so
contentment is about feeling
calm feeling at peace with your life and
your decision so what are those things
in your life
that give you that sense of contentment
and then the third leg is control now
now chris i thought long and hard before
using the word control because
control again is another word that can
feel
problematic to some people and can be
misinterpreted when i say control
i'm not talking about
us
controlling the world right the world is
inherently uncontrollable i mean it
always has been but the last couple of
years have really shown us that right no
matter what we may want to happen the
world is going to just keep going the
way it wants to keep going right
so this is about a sense of control
right what is it that you can do in your
life that gives you a sense of control
and you know we know from the research a
sense of control is linked with
academic success social maturity
health longevity happiness
so
i designed this concept of happiness to
try and
i really wanted to come up with a
complete model but also a practical
model
because
i do think sometimes we have this vague
concept of what these things are and we
can
you know be philosophical about it
and
think about these things as ideas
but my drive to write this book was to
help myself and also to help my patients
right because there's a strong link
between happiness and health which i
think is very much
underappreciated in society it's very
much under appreciated in my profession
so i wanted to make something practical
that people can you know kind of take
with them in their back pocket and take
around with them in their life and try
and figure out
oh this is why this oh this feeds the
contentment leg of the stool that's why
it's helping me with my happiness
oh when i do this
man i'm not acting in alignment that's
why afterwards i feel really crap and i
can't sleep and i keep replaying that
over and over again in my head and so
i've used this model with people
and most people i've come across who
i've i've talked about this model to
love it and they find it a very simple
and practical way of helping
of helping them get more out of their
lives
i think you're right when you say
happiness to different people it means
different things and when you've got
such a big ephemeral diffuse concept
breaking it down into just anything
that's more component parts is going to
help you to be able to work out what
contributes to it i think that the
alignment part is an interesting one
because everybody plays different roles
and puts different masks on depending on
what environment they're in but after a
little while if you're not careful you
can sometimes lose the distinction
between what is the mask and what is you
especially if you've felt like you have
to play a particular role for a long
time maybe being in a relationship that
you haven't been particularly happy in
and you've been lying to your partner so
much for so long that you don't actually
know what you feel about the
relationship anymore
maybe you've been at work in a job that
you feel very unsatisfied in or very
very overly satisfied in or you want to
go somewhere else whatever it might be
this distinction between persona and
personality or real us and fake us
that line begins to get blurred and i
think that's definitely one of the
places that i can see and that the thing
that's real nefarious about that to do
with happiness it won't impact your
happiness straight away
it'll slowly degrade it over time
yeah when you're not alliance for sure
bit by bit it just
it erodes at the core of who you are
like acid it just sits there just sits
there and the truth is chris
like this book is incredibly personal i
have shared stuff in this book
about my life about my insecurities
about my struggles that
i would never have shared even two or
three years ago i wouldn't have had the
courage
to do what i would have been scared of
judgment and what was the scariest story
i think at the start of chapter three
which is entitled treat yourself with
respect
i started off talking about when i was
at university edinburgh medical school
and on a sunday afternoon
you know after a couple of nights out
we'd often end up at diane's pool hall
at edinburgh we you know
put some pound coins in the jukebox have
the tunes playing be playing pool
and
here's the thing mate
if i was ever losing
against one of my mates
and i thought man i may lose here
i would go into the bathroom i look at
myself in the mirror
i'd slap myself on the face a little bit
call myself a loser
and then i'd come out and most times
it would give me that drive to sort my
head out and i would normally end up
winning not always but usually
and at the time
you know i just thought that was who i
was i thought yeah i'm just super
competitive i don't you know i like to
win that's that's who everyone around me
thought i was that's who i thought i was
now interesting enough i am no longer
competitive and we can maybe talk about
that later if you want but
i shared you know how i felt in that
moment what i would do in the mirror how
i would talk to myself
and if you know a few years ago i
wouldn't have wanted to reveal that part
to myself like i'm a you know i'm a
doctor in the public eye i'm a
well-respected medical doctor you know
it didn't fit with that idea that i had
in my head of what a medical doctor
should be talking about in public but
again that's a story because
all of us play roles in our life you
know a doctor is not who i am it's
simply one of the many roles that i play
in life
and you know letting go of that identity
has also been a big thing for me in
terms of
feeling happier more calm and more
content so even sharing that
at the start of chapter three
i honestly don't think i would have done
that even two or three years ago and
actually interestingly enough like my
wife who
you know she she's amazing she used to
be embarrassed so she helped set it well
she doesn't help she edits my podcast
um
and
when i'm writing i don't want her to
help me and i say hey babe listen i've
got this idea look can you just read
these paragraphs and tell me does that
make sense
she refuses point blank she goes no i'm
going to wait until the end
and she always wants to wait until i've
basically completed the manuscript so
she can come with a
you know a clear
you know unfiltered mind she could
basically look at it with complete
clarity
and she always makes some really really
insightful comments and gives brilliant
feedback and i'm like oh i haven't
noticed that okay thank you that's
awesome
but with this book the first thing she
said to me
was hey babe listen um
are you sure you want to share all of
this in the book
and it was really interesting because i
thought about it you know she wanted to
protect me she's like are you sure you
want to share some of this stuff about
your personal lives you want that out
there you know you have a large public
profile
and i thought about it and you know what
i just said yeah i'm okay with it like
i'm
i feel really comfortable with it now
i've i've done the work i've gone
through i processed it
i'm not
scared of that like i'm not scared of
showing that part of me in fact
in many ways and i've learned this
through my podcast quiz i'm sure
potentially you have as well you know on
your show but
i quickly learned four and a half years
ago when i started my show
that
the best way the easiest way to do this
week after week is just to be yourself
if you are trying to perform each week
and
you know present a certain image of
yourself to the world or what you think
a doctor should be
that's going to be knackering it's going
to be tiring it's going to be exhausting
and i soon learned that if i was just
myself and opened up and shared the
things that i was struggling with
uh what i found hard where i've learned
something in life i found on those
conversations
not only when more people listen but the
feedback i got people were like oh man
it's so awesome to hear that so it's
great to hear that you've got the same
struggles as i'm going through and so
i couldn't have shared like this a few
years ago because i was scared of
judgments and that scare that that fear
of judgment chris it really comes into
that question that you asked me about
what was one of the most revealing
things
about me and as i say it to you you i'm
i'm thinking well
maybe chris is thinking
well that's not that revealing you know
it's not that revealing and i guess it's
all about perspective but certainly for
me it would have felt too hard but but
but chris i'm really trying to figure
out where this comes from in me
and i really think a lot of it like many
of our personality traits
and
what we think are our behaviors and our
i guess our personalities
a lot of the time they are
adaptations
to what happened in our childhoods you
know they're like defensive adaptations
that we used
to help us get through certain times so
for me
you know my parents were immigrants from
india to the uk 1960s and 1970s right so
they come over
you know dad comes over in 1962 when the
uk government are trying to recruit
doctors from india to fill the gaps in
the uk
and you know he works and he faces
struggle he get you know this
discrimination there's all kinds of
stuff they had to put up with to be
really clear my dad never ever
complained once until pretty much his
deathbed did he share and open up to me
but he just got on with it
that's such an immigrant mentality as
well that isn't totally and actually one
thing that did say to me before we died
chris is
he said
he said son look i put up with it this
wasn't my country i came here from india
i put up with it but you're not going to
put up with it
and man i remember that because
you know dad was so busy working like
when i say working
he killed himself working i opened the
book with with dad's story there's no
question dad slept three nights a week
for 30 years
you know he it was literally
you know as i say in the book like
happiness and success often gets
confused society's definition of success
drove my dad's
he works hard he provided in many ways a
great upbringing
certainly from the outside for my
brother and i
um i didn't really see my dad much
growing up um but i don't resent my dad
in any way for it dad did what he felt
he had to do
but what's really interesting is that
when i was a kid chris
i'd come home from school and if i got
19 out of 20
my parents would say well why not 20.
if i came second in the class it was
always well who came top why didn't you
come top what did you get wrong again
like this is just the most for me from
the outside looking in uh
indian immigrant family with father is a
doctor like son about to be a doctor
this is just straight from the playbook
well exactly and the these all my these
cliches are all cliches because they're
real right they're exactly what happened
so
what one key lesson i've learned for
happiness which we'll maybe talk about
later is perspective is everything
perspective is absolutely everything and
so
this situation right little rongan
showing up after school pretty chuffed
that he's got 19 out of 20
i felt i took on this um belief about
the world when i was young
that i'm only worthy
i'm only worthy of love i'm only enough
when i'm top of the class
when i've got straight a's
when i've succeeded
right and there's no one above me that's
the idea i took on and
i've only realized that in the last few
years i've actually pretty much since
dad died and then
you know i stopped looking for my
answers out there and i started to put
the mirror there and start looking
inside and try and figure out
who i was whose life was i leading why
do certain things trigger me in certain
ways
and
you know i took on that belief that's
driven me to
you know get to medical school be a
doctor get a good job
um you know
by society's definition of success
i've got it right i've got the
respectable job um you know i've written
four international bestsellers and this
fifth one is about to come out now
um you know my podcast is the number one
health podcast in the uk and europe
right from the outside it all looks
fantastic
right it looks it looks wonderful but
for a lot of my life there's been a
feeling of discontentment
underneath it
right and that's why
when i was
in that pool hall at university why i
couldn't stand the thought of me losing
it was it i realized that it wasn't that
i enjoyed winning
it was too painful
to lose well because if you lost that
was a comment on your self-worth as an
individual right exactly
the reason that the world wants me the
reason that i am valuable is contingent
on my ability to perform and to be the
best and i think this is a this is a
very common pattern that i see with a
lot of my friends that are high
performers right yeah that
i would say as much if not more of the
drive
from the people that i know that are
high performers comes from a fear of
insufficiency rather than a desire to do
more right they're filling a hole inside
of themselves i always use this story
eddie hall um i remember i watched this
documentary about him and he said if he
hadn't won the world's strongest man in
2017 2018 that he would have been dead
divorced with no relationship to his kid
because the training protocol and the
substances that he was on he was six
foot three 200 kilos
and murdering himself on a daily basis
in the gym
uh because of how hard he was training
he had no relationship with his wife and
his marriage was on the rocks and he had
no time or patience to see his kid and
his relationship with his child was
ruined now eddie went and won world's
strongest man that year and off the back
of that he's much healthier he has a
better relationship with his kid a
better relationship with his wife and
you know kind of everything's fixed but
the way that we looked at eddie hall's
success we applauded the fact that eddie
succeeded within that very narrow domain
of being world's strongest man there's
glory there's accolade the sponsorships
so on and so forth
but no one actually sees the externality
of that no one sees the price that you
need to pay to be eddie hall or tiger
woods is another example you know
greatest golfer of all time but world's
most public marriage failure can't bear
to be in a relationship
been in multiple car crashes whilst he's
been on antipsychotic drugs falling
asleep at the wheel spent half a decade
out of the sport because of how hard he
was pushing himself due to injury all
that stuff and he got okay would you pay
that price to be tiger woods yeah like
what's the price of success and if the
price of success is happiness on route
to succeeding in an attempt to make
ourselves happy you go hang on so
i've stopped the thing that i'm trying
to get as a part of the outcome that i'm
trying to achieve on route to achieving
that outcome so you go okay so if we
remove the chase of success from that
situation you're just left with
happiness
and it's so strange because there is
still this tension we want to feel like
we're enough we want to feel like we're
contributing to the world
and yet a lot of the time the route that
we take toward that contribution
kills our ability to be happy in the
moment
yeah 100 i mean we see this story played
out
over and over again tiger's a great
example i write a section on tiger in
chapter one and i think i've called it
worshipping the wrong heroes as a kid i
did really look up to tiger if i'm
honest i still do now like that doesn't
mean i condone or don't condone this
behavior it's not for me to judge
another human being in terms of what
they have or haven't done the point is
as a kid
i put him on a pedestal and like many
people do we think we want to be tiger
woods
but i'm not sure we really do like we
think we do but it's like how relevant
is tiger to my life honestly like i may
want to play golf like him but
hey do i have his talent let's even
assume i did have even ten percent one
percent of his talent which i don't but
let's say i did
have i got eight hours a day to practice
no can i do my job i'll look after my
family and practice no it has no
relevance we put these people on a
pedestal that have zero relevance to who
we are and we we worship the wrong
heroes in society because if i'm gonna
worship tiger i gotta worship every part
of him the failed marriage the
the the problems with painkillers the
the deep internal pain and suffering you
can't have one component
and not the whole thing and that's the
mistake we make so these days
you know
i've really been thinking whether heroes
are
a problematic idea in general
for
society
i i think that because if you are i
guess it depends what you mean by hero
if you're putting someone on a pedestal
then
by default you are lowering yourself in
comparison to them right so they are
higher than you they're not equal to you
and i think that can be really really
problematic and it's funny i i was
chatting to my wife about this recently
because she never did hero worship
growing up never
it she she doesn't get it she didn't get
it when we first met that i had this
kind of tendency i wonder if that's a
male trait
potentially i mean i don't know any sort
of research or science on whether that
is the case but it would kind of make
sense to me that
yeah i think certainly the way society
is now where many more many more
stateless driven overall in general yeah
so i think that it would make sense for
us to try and model ourselves off the
people that we see that have the most
status women don't tend on average to be
competing on status as much as men so i
think that
it wouldn't surprise me if that was the
case
yeah so i think i think the kind of
tiger story
is
it's kind of
how many times we need to hear this
stuff before we get the message because
we can keep hearing this stuff yet we
still then get seduced by
this idea that actually this is what we
should be chasing so let me add in how i
think it would be a good way to model
this
i i agree that putting somebody
in totality
on a pedestal and saying this is a
person universally worthy of admiration
and i want to try and model their life
as much as possible i think that you're
correct to say that that's probably not
a good idea but as soon as you
understand this red pill which is that
you can't take part of someone's life
you have to take the whole and the goal
is to be able to find somebody who has
elements that you want to be able to
model yourself off you want to say i
like
tiger's work rate and dedication to his
sport okay i can take that i can take
that as an individual element as soon as
you realize that the
we're all playing at different levels
right there's certain things that people
are better at and you are
not subservient to them but you are kind
of in their shadow a little bit until
you can get to be as good as that person
at that thing
the line that we don't need to cross is
this makes me less worthy as a person
this means that i have less value to
society or less worthy of love and so on
and so forth but if you can pick it
apart and say exactly i like their
dedication to their craft i like the way
that he always makes time for his kids i
like the fact that him and his wife have
a really fantastic communication
strategy or whatever it might be you
know like those are things that we can
pick apart and you can
tease the components of success in that
way yeah i completely agree mate it's
like it's the nuance that we need it's
not that it's all bad or all good it's
like no there is there is potential here
to go that's a really awesome
personality trait okay you know i'd love
to have a bit more of that and
you know to conclude that section in the
book i i wrote about my father-in-law
right because i said i talked about
tiger and then i said you know what
someone i really really look up to these
days
not in terms of putting on a pedestal
necessarily but
i
i think you know going back to the call
happiness stool right we've got
alignment contentment and control
so alignment we're talking about values
your inner values and your external
actions are
they are they the same are they getting
closer and closer to being the same you
know are you aligned in that component
of your life and you know as we speak my
three core values
and i'm constantly looking at them and
refining them and seeing if anything
sits better with me but these have been
pretty static for a good few months now
and they are integrity
compassion and curiosity these are
the values that i think
not i think that i really believe i
bring to every aspect of my life whether
it is as a husband as a father
um as a podcast guest with you now chris
as a podcast host as a doctor whatever
these values
represent a huge part of who i am
and then if you apply that then to my
father-in-law like he's one of the most
incredible men i've ever met
he has so many qualities
but what in particular is i've never
seen him ever raise his voice to anyone
he always speaks with this beautiful
soft compassionate tone
and he has a smile that literally lights
up every room that he goes into he makes
people
feel better not because he's trying to
just by nature of who he is he lifts
everyone up around him and i think well
wrong instead of idolizing tiger woods
like
i'm
i don't think we should idolize anyone
necessarily so i'm not saying i now
idolize my father-in-law but
i'm like well these valleys are much
more relevant to my life right so why
can't i look up to those files and go
yeah wow that's a great model of how to
interact in these settings that i can
take and start utilizing so
again going into that nuance piece i
think that's a really important
i think it's an important way that we
can start thinking about it who do we
have in our life around us maybe not
even people on tv or youtube where we're
only being
i guess we're only really seeing
one side of their personality because
that's what's been presented to us
sure you do long-form podcasts like i do
one of the things i love about this
medium
is that you get to see those multiple
sides to people's personalities that in
the way that you often don't do in
conventional media there's also less
place to hide
right there's less place to hide yeah
you you
exactly in a one hour conversation in a
90-minute conversation
you're going to get a good feel for who
someone is by
by the way they answer all these
different questions but but also the
thing that comes to mind chris is
have you heard of brony care um the
palliative care nurse she wrote the book
five regrets of the dying
and she basically spent years caring for
people at the end of their life
and she wrote a book about what they
told her and there were these five key
things that kept coming up over and over
again so people at the end of their life
they all pretty much say the same things
i wish i'd worked less
i'd wish i spent more time with my
friends and family
i wish i'd allowed myself to be happy
i wish i'd lived my life
and not the life that other people
expected off me
and i can't i don't think i quite
remember the fifth one on the top of my
head
but
again it's the same theme at the end of
our life we know what's important we
look back and regret often that we
didn't do these things
yet so many of us and i was this person
i've i'd like to think i'm no longer
that person in many ways
but
you know this is what and this is where
you know meaning and purpose i don't
know if you've spoken to guests on on
your show before he said look happiness
really isn't what it's about it's about
meaning it's about purpose
i've certainly heard that a lot i've
seen that a lot on social media and i
was trying to put that through the lens
of this core happiness model that i've
come up with i'm thinking well i know
meaning and purpose is important
but is it the same thing as happiness
and again it can be interpreted in
different ways by different people
but i thought well
i don't think it is i don't think it is
either no i don't think it is i think
meaning is a helpful ingredient for
happiness but i don't think it's
happiness in and of itself and i think
it sits under the
alignment leg of the core happiness
stool because
if you are
if you find a sense of meaning and
purpose in your life
you know you are going to be doing
something that's consistent with your
values that's why it has meaning and
purpose for you i think in most cases
and you could also and this is why i
like this call happiness tool i think
it's i think it's relatively complete it
so far i haven't found a situation where
i can't apply it and have it make sense
i'm not saying that doesn't exist and
that might come up at some point but i i
have tried to test it in a whole variety
of different scenarios and i sort of
feel that
like you could have a job that you love
that gives you that strong sense of
meaning and purpose that's helping the
world and you love doing it right
brilliant
sure you're aligned in that moment
you're strengthening the alignment leg
of this core happiness still but you
could also
be working so hard at getting so
stressed out in this job that you love
that you end up neglecting
seeing your partner or your children or
seeing your friends and what do people
say at the end of their life i wish i'd
spent more time with my friends and
family so
what what i love about this is it helps
create a bit of balance to happiness
sure have meaning and purpose in your
job
if that's where you can get it but don't
also work so hard in it that you that
you neglect those other things or you
can make the case you know i don't mean
to be controversial and i hope people
don't take this the wrong way but you
could make the case that a soldier
fighting
in world war ii
you know against the nazis was living a
life of meaning and purpose
right you someone might make that case
it doesn't necessarily mean that they're
happy so
i think there's a bit of nuance here the
other thing i like about taking it away
from meaning and purpose a little bit is
when my second book came out a few years
ago it was called the stress solution
chris and i remember the first
live event i did it was at this big hall
in london
and i gave the talk
and i was doing q a at the end and part
of the talk i spoke about ikigai this
japanese concept
you know where you know this idea that
we hopefully should be trying to find
something in life that we're good at
um that pays us money that we enjoy
doing and it's something that the world
needs and i remember the first time i
read about it i thought oh i like that
you know i want some icky guy in my life
and i was talking about it on stage
three or four years ago
and at the end of the talk this this uh
20 year old lady had her hand up at the
back and i adjusted to her
and she said dr chad she can ask you
something i said sure
said i'm a japanese student
living and studying in london
i grew up with this concept of ikigai
and i always found it very off-putting i
found it too high a bar to achieve so i
got very demoralized by it
and isn't that interesting
i'm talking about this concept that i've
learned about that i think it's
wonderful
and she grew up infused with that around
her and said man it's just too high a
bar to reach and and that conversation
has always stuck with me chris because i
always try and make things accessible to
as many people as possible and i thought
well
meaning and purpose sometimes
if if let's say someone doesn't enjoy
their job
let's say i don't know they're working
in a call center somewhere and a job
that they don't like but that's the only
job that they can get at the moment and
it pays the bills keeps a roof over
their head puts food on the table
they can watch that social media post
and go yeah meaning and purpose what
what on earth are you talking about i
haven't got time for that i just gotta
get through my day and i thought well
how can i unpick that and put it through
the lens of this call happiness stool
and it comes down to alignment and
values
because
if anyone no matter who they are no
matter where they live if they can spend
a bit of time trying to understand
some of their core values they don't
need to put pressure on themselves they
can start with one
but if you start to identify what that
is and you can live your life whatever
you're doing with those values
well i think on some level you are
living a life of meaning and purpose so
if that person in the call center has a
core value of kindness right they go
yeah that's really important to me
okay well maybe you don't love your job
but if when you leave the house in the
morning and you pick up your takeaway
coffee you're kind to the barista
if when you get on the bus and you're
kind to the bus driver if when you're at
work you're kind to your colleagues
well you may not love your job but
you're still living
in accordance with your values you are
living with meaning into your life and i
feel that the more people do that
that will help them over time change
that job in the future but if they start
to act in a way that's not aligned with
who they are they create this big void
and it's in that void
right that's where the junk happiness
habits start to come in
the booze the drugs the gambling
do you know what i mean that's it's to
fill that void when we're not being who
we are so that's kind of how i try in my
head and put that all together for
people and i hope that's a much more
accessible message for a lot more people
one of the problems that you have with
the icky guy lady that asks you the
question as soon as you posit an ideal
you immediately begin to measure
yourself in reference to that ideal and
that basically means that every ideal is
a judge and your ability to be
idealistic is always going to outstrip
reality's ability to deliver that to you
right you're never going to be able to
get to that potential all the time and
this is why
chasing down a potential that's always
moving is like running toward the
horizon right every step that you take
toward it continues to move it further
away that being said i don't think that
that means that we shouldn't have ideals
and we shouldn't have goals and
potentials that we want to try and
achieve
yes it's going to make you feel
uncomfortable because you think well my
job doesn't perfectly align between what
the world needs what i can be paid for
what i love to do and whatever the other
one was however
i understand why that makes people
uncomfortable something else that's
interesting a model of happiness that i
think is is quite useful is the
difference between daniel kahneman and
daniel gilbert's look of happiness so
kahneman's uh justification is the goal
of life is to live a life which in
retrospect you're glad you lived that's
meaning
uh daniel gilbert's definition is
momentary happiness every single moment
more hedonic is an optimal strategy so
an example here would be
you could live the remaining
50 years of your life on a lilo in a
beach somewhere with a cocktail in your
hand and that could be you for the rest
of time now you might look back on that
situation and say
i don't think that i had a lot of
meaning or contributed to a higher
purpose but every moment during that was
happiness right yes it was momentary yes
it was fleeting yes it was very shallow
but there was some sort of very
immediate shallow joy that you got from
that conversely you could go through a
situation where you are the
soldier in world war ii
you believe in the cause that you're
fighting for you're doing something that
you know that's good it's hard there's
camaraderie but it's not happiness in
the moment you're not the guy that's on
the lilo in the middle of the pool with
a cocktail but when you look back on
your life you find that was incredibly
meaningful and
the more that i've thought about it i
don't think that these two concepts can
be blended together particularly easily
i think that many of the things that
cause us to feel meaning in retrospect
aren't things that can provide us with
in the moment hedonic happiness at the
time and this is why having different
elements to the way that you live your
life is important that you have a job
that maybe you really work hard at and
you contribute to
something that you feel that gives you
meaning and then you go home and you get
to you have some friends that you can
just have a laugh with and you have joy
in the moment and this is a more
um multifaceted view of how happiness
and meaning play together and there's
definitely a tension in it uh so yeah i
i think that's a beautiful way of
putting it and
i agree it's on one level it's hard to
have those two things
sit neatly side by side
for me it comes down to
kind of intention you know my role
and my desire is never to
tell people what to do i've never done
that as a doctor like honestly i've
never told a patient to give up smoking
but they have to give up smoking it's
been
as a fairly human being
if that patient comes in to
ask her my opinion
then i will give them an opinion and say
well this is what i think smoking is
doing to these various metrics of your
health
and i you know i i make it really clear
and if they've understood that and
they've retained that and i'm very clear
that they've understood it and they then
say to me hey doctor listen
i hear what you're saying
but i get so much enjoyment out of this
that i'm absolutely prepared to put it
with the downsides
i'm like okay well as a fellow human
being i have to respect that my job is
not to say no you can't no you mustn't
do that you don't understand it's like
no well
at the moment
he does understand and he's made that
choice and actually
you know so far i managed to get pretty
good compliance with my patients in
terms of the things i recommend and i
think one of the reasons is is because
i really do try and treat them with a
level of respect that they are partners
with me i'm trying to help them but i'm
not trying to tell them what to do and
then sort of take that approach to this
happiness model that i've tried to
create i'm not here to say this view of
happiness
is the perfect one and you have to
utilize it in your life and this is the
one that
blows every other one out of the water
now i'm not saying that at all
i'm saying that i fundamentally believe
that
all humans at the end of their life want
to look back and go yeah that was that
was a that's pretty happy life or you
know i really do feel we want happiness
and i've tried to define what i mean by
happiness so this core happiness and
i've tried to make it practical just as
if
you know we know we we understand very
clearly because we've been told this
message in society of many years if we
you know if we do bicep curls every day
in our house or in the gym we are going
to get bigger and stronger biceps we
know that right that's going to happen
we're strengthening that muscle by
working on it
and the point of me creating this core
happiness stool model
was to also show people that hey listen
happiness is also a muscle that you can
strengthen you can work on alignment you
can work on contentment you can work on
control
you're not actually directly working on
happiness
this what i'm trying to do in the book
is break down simple things for people
that they can do that work on these
different legs
and if you keep strengthening those legs
with various practices in your life the
default side effect is going to be
you're going to feel happier more of the
time
why don't you think that dreams will
make us happy now
so that was quite a
provocative subheading in chapter one
your dreams won't make you happy
and
i think for many of us
i don't think our dreams do make us
happy i think our dreams
often come from a place of lack
rather than a place of love and
abundance it's like i don't feel good
enough so when i get that goal when i
get that job when i've made that money
when i can
um
sell my company for this you know what
i'm going to show everyone yeah i i was
that person who can make it and as
you've already demonstrated with a
strong man um tiger um johnny wilkinson
right came to the studio last week we
had a long conversation johnny wilkerson
i know for people who who
you know outside the uk who may not know
johnny in the early 2000s one of the
most famous rugby players in the world
in the 2003 world cup final he kicks
the winning goal for england in the
final minutes of the game right fairy
tale ending when he was a kid
right when johnny was a kid he wrote
down on a piece of paper
i want to play for england i want to win
the world cup
right so by 24 this guy has achieved his
dreams
but he describes this deep sense of
emptiness loneliness anxiety
that accompanied that dream literally
the morning after
the morning after he's delivered his
country the world cup for the first time
in god knows how long
he feels empty nothing literally nothing
and so
this is a story we see repeated over and
over again where people
get their dreams they they sacrifice who
they are they sacrifice the important
things in their life they think when i
get that when i've got more money when i
can stay in a nicer hotel when i go on a
holiday when i can buy a nicer car i'm
going to be happier i'm not saying we
shouldn't go after those things but if
those things are coming from a place of
lack
actually when you get them you will find
that actually that lack is still there
you know so it's a pippa grange on my
podcast a couple of years ago pippa was
um a psychologist who worked with the
england football team
you know maybe 2016 to 2018 she was
certainly in the media credited with
being hugely influential at changing the
mindset in the england team and she has
this gorgeous concept chris
called winning shallow or winning deep
and it's really lovely and it's this
idea basically that how are you going to
win in life right shallow or deep and
she would talk about all these premier
league footballers who were taught to us
she never revealed any names of course
some of the most highly paid footballers
on the planet
right on the planet
they thought when they were kids when i
win the fa cup
like my life's going to be maids and
then they're there literally they win
the fa cup at wembley they lift the
trophy and as they're walking down the
stairs at wembley
they feel that emptiness inside
so what i mean by our dreams won't make
us happy if we're not careful is
basically let's make sure that our
desires our goals our dreams are the
right dreams let's make sure they're
coming from a place of fullness and love
because otherwise you'll end up getting
to that place and you may look back and
go oh my god
what was the price i had to pay to get
here like you say with tiger you know if
i ever ever get the chance to interview
tiger which is one of my dream guests on
the show let's put it out there to the
universe
right now
i'd love to know from target you know
was it worth it was the juice worth to
squeeze yeah was it worth it or you know
when you watched the michael jordan
documentary on netflix
and you know i don't claim to know
michael's story intimately you know i
just don't i but i've i've watched the
documentary i found it really really
powerful
and every time he was talking about you
know using a slight from an opponent as
a way to create a story in his mind
about why he had to get to that next
level
i just thought
man
that can't have been a nice way to live
the tension it doesn't sound healthy you
know but again this is this is because
we have such a
modern society puts fame and success
on such a mountaintop that we're
prepared to accept any sort of price
that someone pays i wrote this
newsletter the other day that i wanted
to read to you actually that i think
kind of relates to this so i was talking
about the
strange way that we applaud fame right
in the modern world do you want to be
someone or do something now the two
aren't mutually exclusive of course but
they're a lot less cohesive than you
might think fame ain't what it used to
be traditionally people became famous
because they achieved something great
maybe even heroic because fame was such
a powerful signal we all started wanting
it well he wouldn't
but this was the downfall of fame people
stopped wanting to do something and
started wanting to be someone regardless
of why the goal is not to deserve fame
just to be famous
once upon a time fame was bestowed on
those who earned it such as a heroic
general who risked his life in battle or
the famous doctor who restored sight to
the poor and afflicted it was heroic
deeds that made them famous today fame
is only granted to those who seek it
that's from the new philosopher fame
itself has been separated from what it
was supposed to indicate it's no longer
a trustworthy signal of honor courage
creativity or anything else except maybe
an above average need for attention so
why do we chase it because modern fame
is the promise of obligation-free status
if you could shortcut the work bit
and just get the reward bit why wouldn't
you and when people become famous for
drinking juice while skateboarding on
tick tock or being picked out of
obscurity to go on reality tv why
wouldn't we try to game that system to
fame roots our happiness in other
people's heads
when a person is inflated with fame the
rest of us have it in our power to
deflate him
other people's heads are a wretched
place to be the home of a man's true
happiness said arthur schopenhauer to be
famous is to volunteer to be a scapegoat
you're treated like a king until you
screw up or people get tired of you then
you're sacrificed at the altar giving
the public someone to hate together
when we put this kind of power in the
hands of those around us our whole sense
of self becomes an abstraction we have
to check our twitter engagement to
measure self-worth instead of the action
that we took
fame can make you happy if what brought
you fame also brings you happiness which
means you would remain happy if your
fame were to diminish
to be somebody or to do something in
life there is often a roll call that's
when you will have to make a decision to
be or to do which way will you go from
john boyd
i love it so much so much there that is
there's so much truth so much to reflect
on that you know as you as you were
saying that chris
like the things that were coming up for
me were this idea of you know fame for
fame's sake you know fame without doing
the work
uh which of course can be done these
days in a way that it could never happen
before and it it also reminded me of
something that happened last summer
so last summer
uh there's a there's a sort of big event
twice a year sorry twice this summer
that chris evans
um that the sort of uh media personality
radio dj in the uk has been running for
years to raise money for charity
and
it's really interesting so the last few
years
you know i've been on television my
public profile has grown significantly
to the point where i
i probably get stopped on most occasions
when i leave the house these days
but i always try and keep my kids and my
family
as much as i can separate from it so my
kids really haven't seen
daddy out doing his work in his job
right so when i'm with the kids i'm you
know i'm unshaven in my shorts just
hanging out in old t-shirts doing
whatever you know i'm not bothered about
that kind of external
type appearance
and last
um
last summer
chris chris invited me to join
uh them at carfest
and do some sort of health and wellness
talks on the hay bales in front of the
the audience for the festival
i thought okay this is yeah this would
be pretty cool and the family were
invited as well to go and camp with
everyone and stuff and i thought okay
this would be a fun experience so anyway
we're going to do the event
right me and chris and a couple of
others talking taking questions talking
about health and wellness stuff that i
love doing sun was shining beautiful
festival
at the end of the event
there was a huge queue of people to talk
to me and i was still there maybe two
and a half three hours later talking to
people and signing things and
it was interesting watching my kids were
watching
and you can see my daughter didn't give
two hoots she was just like who are
these people getting in the way of my
time with daddy like she was just
you know kept wanting me to to leave and
i got the impression my son was quite
liking it
um it was just interesting to watch and
i suddenly started to get really
self-conscious and i thought
oh
what are my kids thinking here you know
i
wanted to talk to my wife i did have a
conversation with the kids later because
i wanted them to be really clear on
something i said look
what did you think of that they go you
know daddy's a lot of people want to
talk to you i said yeah
and i said listen what's daddy's mission
what does daddy try to do we try and
help people i said yeah my mission is to
help 100 million people over the course
of my career live happier and healthier
lives around the world
so i was really trying to get into their
head that i have a mission i have
something that
i'm really passionate about doing
if i
get some way towards that mission
and i help more and more people the side
effect is going to be that more and more
people know who i am the goal isn't for
more and more people to know who i am
that's the side effects of daddy doing
his job properly
so that's what came up for me because i
think it's an important thing to
i think teach the younger generation
particularly in this social media kind
of world in which we're now growing up
where a lot of people do want to get
more followers and more i think the
number one job uh desired job for
primary school kids is youtuber
yeah i mean firemen policemen astronauts
rocket scientists and again look and
again just to be really clear going back
to what we're talking about about
alignment control and contentment
and this kind of deep level of happiness
well there's nothing necessarily wrong
with wanting to be a youtuber i guess
you're a youtuber i'm a youtuber that's
a role that's one of the roles that we
play in life right
but it's where does that desire come
from have you got something wonderful
you want to share with the world that
you're passionate about and you happen
to put that on youtube and the side
effect is that you grow that youtube
following or is that the only goal is
i'll do whatever i need to do
to get
10 000 followers on youtube there's a
big difference and also at that festival
chris i can another story that comes to
mind there is
at the end of the first day
this lovely young lady came up at the
end and she wanted to talk to me about
anxiety
and i helped her i gave her some advice
on what i thought simple things that she
could try and do
and then the next day when we were doing
the events
she also came and she was watching and i
saw her
and at the end she was in the queue
again and i said hey you know really
nice chats yesterday you know um what's
going on and she said listen you know i
was thinking about this um
in september
so after the summer i'm going to study
physiotherapy at uni
and i want to do what you're doing like
you're here spreading wellness you know
you're on stage with chris evans talking
to thousands of people i want to do that
and i said hey look what are you
passionate about she is i'm passionate
about helping people i'm passionate
about mindfulness i want to integrate
that with physiotherapy and i said to
her
okay listen look
i grew up watching chris evans on tv
i've been a doctor for 20 years at this
point
it was only last week that i got a call
from chris's team to come and join him
on stage at this festival
right before that i wasn't doing this i
was doing other things i wasn't doing
this
when my bbc one show came out
like i'd been a practicing doctor at
that point for 14 years right so what i
said to her was listen
i understand that you want this
but my advice to you would be
get really good at what you do if you
love physiotherapy if you love
mindfulness right study it
try and see how you can integrate the
two get really good at that so you then
have something to offer and i promise
you if you get good at that skill
people will come to you and they will
want you to share your message
and i really really thought both that
festival really influenced me because i
thought both from my kids who at the
time were 10 and 8
but for this 18 year old young lady
who's about to you know leave home and
go to university i thought wow this is
such an interesting point let's make
sure people are
you know looking for profile if that if
that's what they are for the right
reasons and in fact
you know yes we can be driven by status
but
it it speaks to i think
what you were talking about there it's
it's what's your reason what what's your
passion why are you doing it and
ultimately if you do it the wrong way
that's when your dreams won't make you
happy because you choose the wrong thing
that you're going to do you end up
getting a level of success but it was
never who you were anyway and i've seen
that as you have chris happen time and
time again to so many people and i think
for much of my life
i've fallen into that trap that's the
truth you know that's why i feel so
passionate about this book because i
feel
i've gone in i've understood it
i've applied the principles to the point
now where i genuinely feel
as happy as calm and as content as i
ever have done and interestingly enough
chris
as we record this conversation
right
we're seven days out from my new book
coming out
right the last four books over the last
four years the the few weeks before the
book came out you know i'd be feeling a
bit nervous
you know what are people gonna think you
know i hope they like it
all this kind of stuff
i don't feel at this time
like i genuinely feel that i've managed
to get to the place where
i know who i am and my self-worth
has got nothing to do
with how well this book does
let me let me push back a little bit
against that and this is something that
i've seen in myself too uh i i agree
that the
lion's share of the work that we need to
do in terms of self work comes
internally right that the external
accolades are not going to fix the
internal void i agree however
there is an element of proof that you
have now
four books deep when they've come out
and they've been well reviewed and
people have been happy and you've got
success and stuff like that
that gives more legitimacy to your
confidence moving forward
you are now at book five
and saying you know i feel less anxious
and so on and so forth and you go what
did you expect to happen if you just did
four bestsellers you know like this is
so my point is
yes i agree internal work
definitely counts
however we can't detract from the fact
that proving your capacities up against
challenges in the real world also
contribute to this i do think that
there's a an element of external
accomplishment that feeds our ability to
trust our own confidence 100 so i think
it's a great point to push back on
i don't disagree with that right so
first of all let me take that aspect
where you direct it to me
right which is yeah well
you know you've written four
international bestsellers of course
you're chilled well that's not the case
for all authors because
often what happens right is that
the bar gets set so high so now the
pressure is on then they will say man
i've had three bestsellers man i hope
this one hits number one as well if it
doesn't you will feel like a failure and
that may seem oh that's a nice problem
to have mate no no that problem for that
individual is real that feels emptiness
that feels like loneliness i know an
author who actually you know their book
was like number 15 in the charts and the
first three were number one
right
and they felt like
crap
like
they would drink more they would stress
out more it would affect their
relationship so i don't think it's a
natural consequence of
me having proven my worth and i agree
that helps i totally agree that helps
having had the level of success that i
have had so far yes it does give that
confidence but i also feel very proud
that i have gone in and i've worked
really hard to get to this point now
where i know honestly
and let's see what happens
but genuinely i i feel see what i do
chris there's a whole chapter in the
book on this chapter 5 which is my
favorite chapter which is
every day for me is a learning day it's
a learning opportunity where i look for
friction in my life to teach me
something about myself
so when i rub up against something that
frustrates me or i wish was other than
the way it is
instead of wishing that the situation
was different or that someone was
behaving differently with me
i put the mirror up and i go okay rongan
what is going on with you why is this
bothering you has this highlighted in
security in you you know what what is
going on that you can grow from because
otherwise you're dependent on the
actions of others and the world around
you for you to have happiness and in a
calm
and i was that person for 30 35 years
well i needed things to go a certain way
to feel good and so i practice it's like
going to the gym mate instead of doing
press-ups in the gym i press up against
other people when i press up against
other people i use it as a way of
learning about myself so i feel
any time i get these pangs of
jealousy or comparison or these kind of
emotions that i've had in the past
i use it as a way to go what's going on
here that's interesting and and so
therefore i feel i could say with a high
degree of confidence now
that i'm coming in thinking actually i
ain't just saying this like i genuinely
feel
if this book was to bomb
right i'm still proud of it i still
believe it to be the very best book i've
ever written and the most important book
i've written but who i am as a person
is not dependent on its success now it
was four or five years ago it was
i also know that my wife and my kids
do not care whether daddy sells one copy
of this book or a hundred thousand
copies they don't and i've learned that
so for me having kids has been
incredibly helpful for me i'm not saying
it's for everyone but for me personally
so that's how i answer the first part of
that
and i guess the other part of that sort
of comment you had was about
you know we do need some degree
of external validation you know that
metric and i agree
we do need people to say you know to
know that you know we have value and
actually our tribe
can see us and they can hear us go yeah
man that's a good job you know you know
that has real value for us
but again i would come back to where
does that desire come from
if that desire comes from sure get the
external validation but if you think
that external validation is going to fix
the whole that you've got inside you
i'm not convinced it's going to do that
so and then that the wider question
chris is
do you need to go through it
to learn it you know can you just learn
it from hearing conversations like this
and hearing people
or do you have to have that adversity do
you have this
this is a perennial question man and i i
i vacillate between it right
part of me thinks that a lot of the
wisdom that we uh
attribute to ourselves and our self work
is just coming along for the ride as a
byproduct of getting older
i i know that we expedite it
i
find tremendous value in great
conversations and insights and things
like that
but it's not about knowing more if it
was knowing more than the most
successful people on the planet would be
the ones that had read the most books
and although there might be a bit of a
correlation that's not the way that the
truth works it's to do with who
genuinely inculcates the things that
they read who applies them in the right
way who resonates with those things and
also who has the most life experience
you know there's tons and tons of
friends that i've got who are
uh bookworm idiots but
life sages you know they've had
endless amounts of interesting life
experiences that bleed into them being
able to understand the way that the
world works so
i
think that you can you can expedite it
but there's an amount of
trials and tribulations that you need to
go through in order to really make those
lessons resonate
i think so or you need to have some
degree of life experience to
put these lessons on and go ah yeah had
i had i sort of thought about it that
way i might have experienced it
differently
but i'm you know chris
one of the most impactful conversations
i've had in my entire life
was on my podcast about two years ago i
spoke to edith eager
right so edith eager when i spoke to was
93 years old
right so when she was 16
she grew up in eastern europe i think
she was getting ready for a date with
her boyfriend that night
and they got a knock on the door
her her sister
and her parents got put on a train to
auschwitz the concentration camp
now she said she'd never even heard of
auschwitz at the time right so they get
to auschwitz within i think two hours of
getting there
both of her parents are
murdered and then later that day
she was asked to dance for some of the
senior prison guards
right
and the first thing she said to me that
i think about on most days is
she said wrong and listen before my mum
left the last thing she said to me was
edie nobody can ever take from you
the contents of what you put inside your
mind
and she said when i was dancing in front
of those prison guards
hours after her parents were murdered
i wasn't dancing in auschwitz i was
dancing in budapest opera house
there was a orchestra playing there was
a full house i was wearing this
beautiful dress that's where i was
dancing i wasn't dancing in auschwitz
i was like okay that's interesting
that's very very powerful reframe
then she told me
when i was in auschwitz i wasn't the
prisoner
the prison guards were the prisoner they
were the ones who weren't free they
weren't living their life in my mind i
was free
i was like okay man that is
that's just so powerful to think that
you can do that
in
these conditions of absolute hell
and the final thing she said to me
that i
honestly think about probably at least
once if not twice a day
is this idea that
rongan this is what this is how she said
it to me i think she said rongan
i've lived in auschwitz and i can tell
you the greatest prison you will ever
live inside
is the prison you create inside your
minds
and what i took from that
and it has such a big influence on my
life and this speaks to whether we have
to go through stuff yeah we have to go
through some stuff but i think we can
also learn
from people at the extremes of life who
have gone through stuff and come out the
other side with
an incredible degree of forgiveness
empathy um compassion and calm
and i think
well if edith eager can reframe
any condition
in auschwitz i'm pretty sure in my life
most of the things that bother me i can
reframe and so this comes down to this
whole idea of seeking out friction i
look for friction
all the time i welcome it i promise you
i know that sounds ridiculous i welcome
it i didn't used to it used to bother me
oh man i can't believe they did that
can't believe they just cut me up in the
roads can't believe they sent an email
with that tone do they not know that i'd
already done this this and this you know
whatever disempowering narrative you
want to tell yourself
but
i've i've now practiced so regularly
that i feel
most of the time i'm not perfect so i
probably don't do it all the time but
most of the time in the moment
i can reframe a situation to choose what
i call a happiness story now this goes
to a wider point chris which i think i'd
love your view on this but
it all comes out of perspective like a
huge part of our happiness comes from
our ability
to choose a narrative and a perspective
that works for us that makes us feel
good and calm and content
rather than taking that sort of victim
narrative which many of us have learned
from our parents we've learnt from
society and actually just creates
emotional stress in our body which is
why a lack of happiness can also lead to
very poor physical health outcomes in
your life
and
like
so it comes to this point for me is what
is the truth does the truth actually
matter
for our happiness
and a lot of the time i don't think it
does right take take the example of a
couple let's say a married couple who've
had an argument
right
what happens
well it kind of depends who you ask if
you ask one party they're likely going
to give you one story about what happens
you ask the other party on the other
side of the table
they'll give you another completely
different narrative over the same
situation right so what what really did
happen
football fans there was a psychologist
studied this
two different sets of football fans were
shown the same incident
on a video replay
and they were you know this wasn't in
the middle of the game this is when they
were feeling calm and i think you know
in control of her emotions what happens
two completely different narratives of
the same situation
and what does that teach us it certainly
teaches me that
any situation has multiple perspectives
so why not choose a perspective that's
empowering and makes you feel good let's
say
march 2020 right in many
countries around the world
certainly in the uk we were seeing
images of empty supermarket shelves
with no toilet roll on them
right people are getting wound up so i
can't believe who would who'd be taking
all the the toilet roll you know
complete people are now you know coming
out with trolleys full of um
you know six or seven packets
okay and a lot of people are getting
worked up out of judging others and
criticizing others
it's like well hold on a minute let's
just think about that for a minute what
actually has really happened how can we
create a narrative
that actually makes us feel calmer
content more in control of the worlds
well
it could be
that every single person who went to the
supermarket that day picked up one extra
role and the supermarket only planned
for their usual kind of
consumer habits okay maybe that's what
happened maybe no one took loads
uh maybe someone did buy 10 packets but
maybe they've got
ulcerative colitis and they go to the
toilet 20 times a day and they are
literally petrified
of the thought
of not having any toilet roll and the
impact that would have with them
socially and with their family
maybe it's someone who cares for four
elderly grandparents and they're like
man i'm gonna need this over the next
few weeks and so they picked up or what
if maybe someone bought 20 packets to
sell on ebay
right can we still have compassion there
well what if
we look at it like well what's going on
in that person's life where
you know what
how bad or maybe that person in their
life feels they've got no opportunity
no money they can't see a way out and
actually thought oh man this is the best
opportunity i've had to make some money
in the last two years
right when we walk round to the other
side of the story i promise you can
train yourself to think like this
i've trained myself to think like this
not always but mostly and the difference
it makes
is just incredible because you feel
karma you have more compassion for the
people around you
and it leads to less junk happiness
habits right we've all got go to
unhappiness habits that we use to kind
of
numb discomfort or numb pain or distract
ourselves you know i've had many you
know in my 20s i'd gamble a lot you know
never to the point where you would say
oh wrong has got a gambling problem
but if i think back it's like well i
would gamble on anything casinos card
games games of pool the football matches
whatever
again i'm not criticizing that but i
could see now with hindsight
it was to fill the void that i had in my
life but as i've i think sort of got rid
of most of that void i have no need for
that behavior anymore so i don't think
i've gambled in 10 plus years i've not
tried to stop
i just have no need for that behavior
anymore so the the way i put it together
for people and i hope this is helpful
chris i'd love your feedback on this as
what you think of this but
the phrase which encompasses it for me
is
if i was that other person
i'd be acting in exactly the same way as
them
right what i mean by that is if i was
that person and i had their childhood
and i had their parents
and i had their bullying experiences
and i had their toxic first boss
right well i'd probably have ex not
probably i would have exactly the same
view of the world as they do and
therefore i'd be acting in exactly the
same way i've heard this
in many different ways in the past um it
certainly was brought home to me in a
conversation i had with peter crone on
my own podcast i know you've spoken to
peter as well
but i've got to say that phrase i think
is it's been life-changing for me and if
people really embrace it
and that would be a challenge i have to
be we'll try that for seven days any
time you get frustrated with the actions
of someone else
just try and go down that path in your
mind if i were them i'd be doing the
same and just watch what happens i i
promise you mate it's been
transformative for me
i think that the frame and the narrative
that we put around the present moment
largely determines our experience of it
right that the difference between
finishing a workout and being sweaty on
the floor and gasping for air and
high-fiving your friends and
spontaneously feeling that whilst sat in
traffic
is the difference between you feeling
satisfied at the end of a workout and
ringing an ambulance because you're
terrified of why is my heart rate so
high why is my
why am i sweating why can't i breathe
you'd think you're having a panic attack
so the same sensation can be interpreted
in two very different ways
and yeah the frame that we put around
the present moment does largely
determine our experience of it and what
we tell ourselves about what it means
because it's very rarely about
the thing that happened yeah right it's
not about the fact that somebody cut you
up it's about the fact that they could
have hit you or they could have made you
late for work or they could have lost
you money because of the insurance claim
or time because of all of the paperwork
it's the story and the implications of
what happened yeah
absolutely and then let's take that one
step further why am i you know a medical
doctor with almost 21 years experience
now seeing patients why
why am i spending my year writing a book
on happiness right do you get books on
happiness by doctors i don't know i
don't know one
right but because
this is a very much under appreciated
connection i think
in society and with the medical
profession
let's take that moment someone cuts you
up right
and you go down the narrative of what an
idiot can't believe they did that do
they not know how to drive they
shouldn't have a driving license
whatever right
do you think you feel calm in that
moment
do you think you feel content no
you feel stressed that emotional stress
will lead to physical stress in your
body it's that's just the way it works
right it's not in it might feel
invisible but it's not it actually has a
tangible effect on your body
if you hold on to this kind of stress
this can cause health problems we see it
time and time again
inability to forgive holding on to
resentment feeling anger like these
things are strongly associated with
things like cancer autoimmune disease
heart disease strokes
high blood pressure right yes i've been
very passionate about promoting how
important lifestyle changes in the
public for many years you know small
changes to food movement sleep and
relaxation have a huge impact on our
overall health
but the reason i wrote this book is
because i was thinking well
why is it that some people
despite making all these great changes
are still struggling of course there are
some genetic components i i don't mean
to say that that's not the case but for
many things it's like there's something
else going on here
and i've seen patients who have the
perfect diet they go and move their
bodies regularly they sleep seven to
eight hours a night
but they allow the actions of other
people and the world around them to
adversely affect their internal states
that is why they stay sick that is why
they keep coming in to see me that is
why they can't
you know break free from some of these
health problems so
why i'm so passionate about these ideas
and these messages is that
yes they've helped me personally in my
own life and i've shared a lot of that
journey in the book so it's not just me
well i hope it's never me lecturing
people i always just try and share
information if people find it useful
great if they don't okay no problem but
i hope they find it useful
i've utilized it with my patients and
found
yes huge improvements for them in their
inner in in their mental well-being but
also their physical health
and i've shared these ideas with friends
and family and seeing the benefits in
their life so for me
like i i i kind of feel that these a lot
of these ideas
are quite simple
none of them certainly none of the ones
i've written about cost any money at all
right these are
super simple ideas that are very very
accessible all it requires is someone to
go you know what
yeah
i think that's me i think i allow my
inner peace and calm to be affected
probably too much by the actions of
other people some people think well how
can that not be the case a lot of people
will say
yeah but of course if someone behaves
like this to me of course i'm gonna feel
bad
well not necessarily you can absolutely
train yourself to not feel bad it can be
a bit of work it can take a bit of time
i'm not suggesting for one minute people
are going to hear this conversation or
get my latest book and actually apply
the principles and suddenly go oh man
life's awesome now
no it's a bit of work but it's not as
hard as people think and you can get to
the other side and
kind of when you do
you kind of feel in control of your life
and i i re this is what you know you
asked me chris how was i feeling at the
start
i think this is why i feel
this deep sense of calm these days
because i've realized actually actually
i create
my response to the world in my mind i
create the feelings like i'm responsible
for them i used to be reactive
now i really do feel i can see that
space
where i go oh i can i can choose
a multitude of different responses to
say which response here
is going to make me feel happier and
better about the worlds and this is
something i really really try and
instill in my kids so going back to
another point we were talking about i'm
hoping that my kids
well they probably do have to go through
some adversity at some point to learn
important life lessons i'm kind of
hoping that
maybe they don't need to wait till
they're 40 to kind of learn some of
these lessons time will tell me you can
interview them in 20 years and see if
they see if they think this is a good
approach or not uh let's bring this one
home mate where should people find you
if they want to check out your stuff
online
well look the new book is happy mind
happy life in the uk it's ten simple
ways to feel great every day the
subtitle in america it's
the new science and mental well-being
different different titles and subtitles
for different audiences but that's
available everywhere happy minds happy
life
probably instagram if you want to follow
me and contact me or you know my weekly
podcast feel better live more so people
like what they have heard and they want
to hear more yeah do get in touch send
me a dm and uh i hope you enjoy the book
until next time mate i appreciate you
thanks chris appreciate it what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you